Eddie Robinson who is one of the
featured artists in the first show on
the first floor show on the world chess
Hall of Fame actually Christian
introduced that a few days ago painted
pieces beautiful exhibit indeed and she
also gave an artist talk and we did a
workshop which she hosted so she's gonna
tell ya
and I mine was a disastrous because I
did alright where's the evidence
yes Lenny Robinson she is indeed an
artist but she's also a jazz singer and
saxophonist as well multi-talented lady
I have here to my right Betty welcome to
the show thank you you had this great
lecture you gave us on painted pieces
that was all about art and and and chess
the connection was how that idea came
about the idea for that particular piece
I did so when I was asked by by Simon of
pearl in London to put a set together
for this show I decided to do something
that had a message so it was bringing
bringing a kind of looking at the
plastic pollution and the bleaching of
corals and sitting out on the on the
board actually sort of creating a
beautiful set but also that had a
message as well and all the pieces in
this exhibit had some kind of messages
that we're seeing there on the screen
right now just absolutely fantastic
pieces you look at this and the artists
that were given this task what exactly
did you tell them
well um everyone the key thing is
everyone was given the same set so we
all got classic stones and pieces and
using that as a as a blank canvas it's
amazing as you can see how many
different sets that you can get it's
endless so every artists have their own
take on it some were were purely
decorative some had a message and and
some were were really playable and
others were deliberately not so they
were actually very very difficult some
were sort of almost like camouflage so
as you move the pieces it becomes very
difficult to differentiate and the idea
of that
chaos and turmoil going on on the
absolutely beautiful and then we got to
create our own chest that says well we
were States I had a great fun behind us
it was a little bit torturous I spent
about an hour and a half on my little
Queen that was doing afterwards and that
was an interesting process how do you
lead people who are amateurs
yeah well I've done quite a lot of
teaching and so so I've done that I
think the most scary one was I did a
portraits workshop where I had to stand
in front of an in huge room of people
painting in front of them and
demonstrating but I've run regular
classes thinking very carefully about
all these designs and the colours is
great and you actually make an actual
chest yeah that's right so the plan is
that I'll take everything back to the UK
and I will create a board so it'll be a
painted board and then everything will
be professionally like it and it will be
be sent out here to be an exhibit where
artists to the resume you also use chess
as a major theme in your art and today
we have many images of you drawing the
chess players we're playing in this
tournament I'm sorry it's just quite
fantastic as you see they're a great
piece of unknowns what motivated you to
want to do this I know you're a chess
player yourself yeah did you enjoy the
game but look Aronian there as well tell
us why you were motivated to UM to make
some part of the players yeah well it
really my my arts is is always about
things that I'm passionate about
so chess or something I got into
relatively recently and
because I absolutely love portraiture it
makes sense to do pictures infirm of the
actual grandmasters appalling hey this
was interesting this is a commission
someone wanted this
they found online and adverts of for
milk I think it's just milk and they
just thought it would be hilarious image
at the end it gives off in the cow wins
be in their world championship match
it's great I love the image here we just
captured his intensity as a player the
board MVL indeed yes so what I'd like to
do with these is I'll take video footage
and take my own stills so it's actually
good because then you could feel
something you get sense of what's going
on and you get sense of how they're
moving and how they're how they are at
the board and I find that's a good way
of just taking a snapshot of reports of
some videos those in your possession in
London yeah see that when I visit yes
and then later in the year yes you're
also just stepping aside for just for
just a quick second yeah you're also a
singer in saxophonist I yes I am yeah so
so music is another big thing for me and
singing is something I've done forever
and yeah so I I do a lot of a lot of
singing I do quite a lot of stuff with
my husband Tony woods he's fantastic as
a saxophonist and he's also a great
songwriter so we've written
he's written loads of really amazing
songs we'd sing
final question yes your favorite in this
sort of int you have a favorite player
Wow oh gosh no I know it's that's a
shame that's a tough that's a tough call
I think I know who I was talking to
Simon before right before I came over
here and he said how great it would be
if Saviano do they might you know did
the job here and thank you so much you
really appreciate your work is fantastic
and I want to see my my chess pieces oh
you will
it'll be lovely Nettie Robinson artists
singer saxophone is chess player what
doesn't this lady do great stuff and
it's just a quick question for you and
Eddie because when we did the workshop I
thought it was really cool the way you
set it up you divided the class into two
halves one one part of the class had
warm colors and the other part of the
class had cool colors so that the chess
sets will be distinguishable their
colors tell us a little bit yeah
absolutely so so I was I was thinking
about some things that you could do and
I always think it's important to have a
set that's not only lovely and painted
and individual but also playable
certainly when I've done any of the the
chess sets with purling London I've
always made sure that they're
differentiated so we thought having warm
colors one side with with a nice gold
color and the the cool side including
xand silver and it would be great
because you could just use whatever from
the palette of potential colors but
there it all go together because we made
sure that no one swapped paint